hi there this morning i am in osoyus
british columbia i haven't been doing
any language learning for the last three
days i've been enjoying the sunshine and
the wine
this is i think it's lagos soyuz behind
our motel
and a lot of people don't know that we
have a great wine growing area here in
the interior of british columbia
produces excellent wine
and
it made me think so today i'm not even
going to talk about language learning
but
but i'm going to talk about
international trade because
just like languages
trade is all a part of how
the world has become smaller
and
um
the standard of living that we enjoy
the fact that so many people in india
and china have come out of poverty and
in other areas the quality of our life
today depends on international trade
there is this thing called comparative
advantage
so
for example in the trade of
steel products
the united states exports more steel to
canada than canada does to the united
states but there is still a significant
flow of canada is the largest exporter
of steel to the united states
why well maybe it's because
certain steel mills produce certain
types of steel which they the canadian
mill might sell to the us or the u.s
mill might sell to canada or maybe a
certain steel mill is located closer to
certain u.s consumers or vice versa and
all of this
improves
the standard of living because it's
efficient and efficient economy benefits
us in so many ways
so the reason i talk about that is too
really one is i see a tweet this morning
from president trump saying how he's
going to
come to canada now to defend the u.s
against all the evil countries of the
world
because the united states has quote
according to trump the worst trade deals
ever made the worst trade deals ever
made
um i was in the forest industry i am in
the forest industry in canada and the
united states slammed canada with an
unfair
um basically
trade agreement that forced canada to
reduce its market share from 36 percent
to 25 percent because the american
forest industry lobby
was able to persuade
congressmen or whatever
that that was in the interest of the
americans it wasn't in the interest of
the american consumer but it was in the
interest of the american forest industry
lobby and on and on and this is the
nature of trade negotiations you have
lobby groups in different countries that
either try to protect certain industries
or try to uh provide advantage of
certain industries and governments kind
of pick and choose who to support and
then they negotiate with other countries
and to suggest that the united states
has the most unfair trade agreements
ever is beyond childish
and relating it to wine
i was watching tv and this person kevin
mccarthy who i think is a leading
republican in the states
said do you and when asked about why are
you slamming canada with
a steel and aluminum tariffs
and of course the reason provided by the
by trump and gang is that it's somehow
very important to security which is
completely ridiculous because the united
states buys not only steel but
sophisticated electronic equipment from
overseas suppliers from japan and
elsewhere so they're no longer more
at risk by buying canadian steel than
they are by buying japanese technology
but leaving that aside
he said no you know what the nasty
canadians do they won't let us sell our
wine in canadian supermarkets kevin
mccarthy tells his american audience
well the fact of the matter is there
isn't one percent of canadian wine
that's sold in supermarkets it's
overwhelmingly sold in liquor stores
and in liquor stores american wine is
prominently displayed in the american
section along with french wines in the
french section and italian wines in the
italian section argentinian wines in
argentinian section as well as the
canadian domestic wines but the
impression created by mccarthy is
somehow canadians won't let
the americans sell their wine the u.s
has 15 percent market share in the
canadian wine market
canada sells no wine in the united
states
the fa the truth is that
very recently in british columbia one
province the government introduced the
sale of wine in supermarkets and in my
opinion very unwisely said that we will
only sell bc wines in the bc
supermarkets and this was done for
political reasons because there was a
resistance to selling wine in
supermarkets
whatever the reason it's a bad idea
protectionism of whatever kind buy local
just as in the united states by american
you know government procurement in the
united states has to buy american all of
this is wrong in my opinion why should
the government of bc tell me what wine i
can buy in the supermarket but for
mccarthy to suggest on television cnn
that somehow canadians are preventing
americans from selling their wine in
canada is also very misleading so it's
very discouraging to see all this
hyperbola and and distortion around what
really should be
a cause for
you know rejoicing that we are able to
trade with all kinds of different
countries and improve our standard of
living and where there are specific
issues like
the fact that the bc government decided
to limit
supermarket sales to bc wines go to the
world trade organization and fight it
and the bc government will be forced to
remove it because it's a totally
unreasonable provision anyway there you
have it today
not about languages but about trade
about relationships between countries
and economies and we all benefit from it
bye for now
[Music]
you